From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Wednesday, March 13, 2013. My name is John Dittmer and I am here in Tchula, Mississippi with videographer John Bishop to interview Mrs. Julia Matilda Burns, a leading civil rights activist in a Holmes County movement.
This interview will become part of the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture in Washington, D.C.
As Burns were delighted to be here today and we thank you for taking the time to talk with us.
Thank you very much. I hope I can give some service to you all.
We would like to start by talking about where you were born and raised in your family.
I was born and raised in Greenwood, Mississippi. In the family we have one brother and three sisters, mother Margaret Griffin, father Trevenu Griffin.
By the age of three we moved to Humphreys County.
What did you do there?
Well, at that time in the early forties the government was purchasing land to yield people their own home.
So my father took advantage of that situation because we were living in the city of Greenwood on the streets of the same.
No place to play or nothing like that. So he decided that we all go to the country.
So we moved to Humphreys County and on that set up we bought a government plot.
the Farm Security Administration (FSA). Right, the Farm Security Administration (FSA).
In any way we got, I think it was 123 acres of land to farm and etc.
And that gave us a stepping stone to progress.
What is your father's life cotton?
We had cotton, corn, can, truck patch and we had chicken, hogs, cows, guinnies, ducks and everything.
You got names.
Four forests.
Right. I had all the never-never land. I guess you call it.
Well, I had to come out of the camp.
Three boys, one boy and three girls.
I'm the second one on the list.
My brother's older than I. He's in Buffalo now.
But I have a sister still on the home place in civil setting.
And I have a sister in Chicago and one in Oak Park, Michigan.
We've only two here in Mississippi. Here by this left.
Right, they did. They left.
My brother left earlier than anyone because he wanted to help me go to college.
I finished high school and he decided that he was going to help me go to college.
My father thought it would be best for me to stay and get an education.
So he went to New York and got a job with John Motors.
And that's how I got my education.
He would work and send money back home and help me get an education.
Who went up on the farm? Did you get all the kids' pitch-in?
Everybody had to pitch in.
Unfortunately, my mother passed when I was only 13 years old.
So I had to shift position early in life, become the head of the household as a female.
And my sisters and brothers continued to work on the farm.
But I was mostly part farmer and part housekeeper.
Hepp and all of us get together.
So you got to grow up overnight?
I grew up overnight.
So what about your school and your what you were at moved out of Greenwood before you were in the first grade?
Right.
Moved out of Greenwood by the age of four.
In fact, I remember correctly.
But my brother was six.
And we moved into the Humphreys County area near school.
And my brother was a kind of person that he would always pick on.
So my mother was a teacher.
So to keep her from being in the middle of the children's fight, I went to school too.
So I wasn't one who was fighting from her brother.
He was start to fight, but he couldn't do nothing with him.
So I had to fight the big boys off of him.
So that made me get a start in school earlier.
So I started to school.
And I was at about four and a half years old.
And I made a fight.
And at home with my mother, you know, naturally she's going to teach us how to read and write.
I was able to do my reading and writing.
And then I got the little do-fund, the little paper bag book.
Find another do-fund, a little bit harder.
And find a hot bag book in one year.
And so many worries.
And that time it was considered a third grade.
So that's the way I moved on up.
And eventually called up with my brother.
He was ahead of me, two years ahead of me.
But I eventually called up with him.
And we went on through grandma school and high school together.
And he was not much over.
Two years older than I.
He skipped two years.
He skipped two, made two years in one.
Tell us about the school.
During that time it was, it wasn't a plantation school, but it was old.
It wasn't an old building either, but it was an old time.
It because they had the pot bellest stone to heat.
Children had to get wood to start to find, keep warm with everything.
At that time there was two teachers, two teachers in the whole big room,
from one through eight.
So how did that operate during the day?
During that time it was marvelous.
Because the two teachers was, I guess you would call it now,
or teacher in a principal.
Because the eight grade person was the overseer.
It went well.
And you learned from the classes ahead of you two.
Yes, I did.
Because a big open setting.
The upper brain was always more interested.
You can hear everybody's in the classroom, you know.
Paying attention, you could know what the other people were doing.
There was no advantages to what happened.
It was.
And in a way we made it well through that situation.
And after, I guess, probably three years, they consolidated the schools.
And the teachers never going to, the lower part of Humphreys County's county,
as compared to us in the center part of Humphreys County County, came together.
And they named the school, Humphreys County, now they named the school, Womack and Hodge.
The Hodges were down on the lower end of the county.
And the Womack was in the middle of the county.
So we went to, the school then became Womack and Hodge.
We stayed there until after graduation.
I guess seventh grade, then they built a new school.
And they called it the Womack High School, too.
And that school went until eight grade.
After eight grade we went to Louise to Humphreys County County.
The still in Humphreys County County, Humphreys County County Training School in Louise Mississippi.
Now, what did you enter, what year did you enter the Louise School?
It must have been in 50, 50, 50, 51.
And there was nine grades.
Stay there until 54, after 54, finishing high school,
I went to Mississippi Valley State University.
I went about a little later.
54 was also the year of the Brown decision.
Not at that time, not at that time.
You know, it probably was in the new, but you know how you thought at that time.
News is news.
And if it doesn't affect anyone, you know it doesn't register with you.
But later on in life, I realized what was going on with Brown v. Board of Education.
Of course, nothing happened in Mississippi anyway.
No, no, no, no. That was in Kansas City, so that bypassed us quite a bit.
One of the things that the state of Mississippi tried to do anticipating Brown was to beef up the black schools
so that they could say we're separate, but we're equal.
Did you see any of that?
Anything coming into your school that's like new buildings or materials or anything?
None whatsoever.
Not at all.
Not even textbooks.
Yeah.
What about textbooks?
Textbooks.
Now, in my ninth grade year in Humphreys County Training School, I saw new textbooks
because they introduced a class that was called Everyday Science.
And there were no everyday science before then.
So once they introduced that everyday science in the Humphreys County School District,
that afforded us to have new books.
The first time seeing a new book was in my ninth grade year.
And the rest were passed down from the high school.
So I lost my train as well here.
But you were...
Well, let me just go with this because it was time here in the 1950s.
And there is racial violence going on.
And asking everybody about the Emmett Till case and what you remember about it.
Recalling the Emmett Till case.
I'm not good at the date now.
But anyway, 55, 55, I was finishing high school that year.
We used to get, we'll call it a jet magazine, still in publication.
And that's why I saw and was able to read the story on the Emmett Till situation.
And then the high school jet first.
No, no, it came to my home.
Yeah, because I think they mean loudness.
No, he got it in home.
My mother and father were kind of people who thought we need to keep with newspapers and stuff like that.
And we did get them.
And that was the magazine that we all raised to read because we could read about what other black people were doing.
That's when I remember what was going on with him.
That's how I recall him.
I remember the picture of the body, which was terrible.
I just couldn't believe it, but it was true.
Do you remember any kind of discussion in the family or with your friends about this?
Because he was not much, quite a little bit younger than you.
Well, my brother, my father always tell him, be careful.
Don't bother them, white girls.
Don't play with the white girls.
Even though they were known in our community, even the boys go everywhere, so to say.
And he had access to the family vehicle, so he was moving around.
And my dad would always tell him not to whistle, let them not to play with them, you know, just ignore them.
But now, believe it or not, there were some black boys in Belzoni, the situation.
It's Belzoni that's sitting down.
They had white girlfriends at that time.
And nothing was done about it.
People would see them.
They were walking together, riding together, and etc.
Nobody paid an attention to it.
But no one wanted to be falling in the footsteps of Emmett Till.
The trial was held, and the people were set free.
And things sort of took off from there in terms of...
I was telling Ms. Head that a number of civil rights activists, you know, sort of pointed to the Emmett Till case.
Attorney Boyd and their lives, from that point on, they realized something had to be done, because that could have been them.
Yes, that was a serious time in our lives.
When you look back at...
No one wants to repeat that situation.
And they had the film set up and everything, and she'll divide it, and that picture came through in the jet magazine, and it was just a horrible sight to see.
What talk about another institution in the air community of the church?
Was that important to you?
Extremely important to us.
Believe it or not, we grew up between a Baptist church and a Methodist church.
There was a sanctified church further down.
So every Sunday morning, we had to be in one.
The Baptist of the Methodist.
We didn't have a...
I don't know where we had a church. We just had to go.
But the Baptist church was closer to us than the Methodist church.
We could actually walk to the Baptist church, even though we were Methodist by faith.
And we would go every Sunday morning.
Our pastor, he was the fourth Sunday in the month.
The fourth Sunday in the month, there would let us use the truck to go to our church.
But anyway, we stayed with the Methodist church, but we just attended the Baptist church.
If something special was going on in the sanctified church, we would call it.
We were right to see that, but some of our friends would have to pick us up
because it was further down the road than our church.
So religiously, we had to be involved.
You were family of faith.
Right. We were always in one church or the other, every Sunday.
Then we still...
I'm still Methodist.
You didn't make your Jewish.
I made my choice.
What were the major influences on you when you were growing up?
My major influence that I could recall was my 10th grade English teacher.
Very smart lady.
Very smart.
And she just had a liking for people who wanted to do something.
I guess she could see in me what I could not see in myself.
And she suggested to me that I should go to college in major English.
And that's what I did.
And I think about her continuously now, you know, what an impact that was on my life, you know.
You know, 10th grade children don't think about their future.
You know, they're just having a good time.
And by them, you know, during that time, in the back of...
During that time, teachers took an interest in children where they are being in their future.
All the way through high school, there was some teacher telling you what you ought to do, what you should do.
And those teachers even visited the families in the community and told the parents,
your child did this, your child did that, and believe it not, you know, if it's good, the parent will work with it if not the parent will try to correct it.
So she told me that I should become an English teacher.
And I worked toward that end.
And I went home and I told my "Daddy, I said, Dad, miss...
She said, I'm going to first name, so I need to go to school to become an English teacher.
He said, you want to teach English?
I said, she said, I want to be pretty good at it.
And that's what I decided to do.
And he said, okay, well, I do what I can to help you.
I finished school at the year.
My brother went off to work and my father and I went through the educational process.
And we were about three miles from the bus stop.
I rode the bus to college.
We didn't have enough money to stay on campus, so I rode the bus.
So you were the only one of your siblings to go to college then?
At that time, yes.
And laid on my sister next to me, went on, but she had gone to Chicago.
She went to Malcolm X College.
The Malcolm X College College?
Okay, she went there.
As a former 10th grade English teacher, I'm interested in what the school class was like.
What books did you read?
Did you have access to libraries?
We had access to library books.
And we could check them out and take them home with us.
But not like now, you know, the children cannot take them away from the school.
They have to study them in the school.
We could take them home and keep them with the week or so, whatever you were doing with either returning home.
You know, with either returning home and you know, you used the book to your advantage.
What did you remember reading?
Oh my goodness.
Way back then.
I was crazy about Alfred Lord Tennyson.
He was a good poet and I would just sit and read for days, some of his poems.
And that inspired me too, too.
That was another one.
I can't think of it.
It got a poem was one.
I guess that was another one.
But I just like the reason because they were in tune to nature.
I like nature and the activities that's there.
Did you read any black writers that you read?
I mean Richard Wright on the screen.
Oh yes.
But I read his book, Soul On Ice and I got made.
It's Soul on Ice.
I said, Violet.
You ever said Eldridge Cleaver?
Right, right.
That's right.
You ever said Eldridge Cleaver?
No, right.
I didn't get a chance to, I didn't like that too well.
I guess it reminded me so much of what I had heard about a little wealthy, you know.
So talk about it.
Now Mississippi Valley, as I recall, was a new school.
Mississippi Valley was built in 1950.
I think that's when they had the first class.
I think I had two buildings or three buildings.
What many buildings there?
But they had an administration building and a classroom building and something else at that time.
I went to school there through the, I guess you call it, classroom building.
Everything was in one building.
All of the majors were operated from one building.
We didn't have access to the whole, you know, building like they have now.
So everything took place in one building.
How many students were there?
I don't recall.
It wasn't that many because the class that graduated in 152, 1816, it was 16 or 32 between the two, 16 or 32 students.
And that was it.
Small student body at that time, but it has grown quite a bit now.
Different majors.
How many majors were there at the beginning of us that started out small?
I think they were predominantly education.
It was designed to give people a chance to major in education.
President Dr. White, James Herbert White, came with the idea that they needed teachers in the Delta.
And he came out of Tennessee, I'm for gun, we're part.
Now, came out of Tennessee and this was his goal to create opportunities for teachers to be developed in the Delta area.
Can someone graduate?
I graduated in 55.
59, 59, 59.
Did you have any new student teaching as part of this?
We had to do student teaching.
That was a requirement at the time.
We had to do student teaching and the student teaching would come out and observe you and all like that.
What did you do?
I did my in Belzoni, where I grew up in Humphreys County.
It was a building that was made in high school at the time.
It was made in high school in Belzoni.
What was the high school life at something that we don't hear very much about?
The school life in the 1950s at the end of the segregated era.
The school life for me, I guess it took a turn for exploring.
It was a time where I was really trying to find out what is going on and why is going on along with trying to get a decent education.
When you were student teaching, what were your students?
Did they have aspirations to go to college or what were they?
I had some very good students as a student teacher because I don't know where you heard of Clare Ried and Bells on it.
That was one of my students.
But then I had some on the flip side all together different from her.
Clare Ried and Cara Harris and Selvam Mohu turned out to be very productive people.
I remember them. I see them. I ask about them.
Some of them are doing well and some of them are not.
Aspirations for them.
It was kind of so, so, so, so.
And then you got your first teaching job?
I got my first teaching job there.
But I wasn't married at the time.
After being there for a while, I got married in my second year there.
Then I went to Chicago.
I didn't do anything in Chicago.
The Chicago was not the place for me. That's why I'm here now.
The Mississippi wasn't the place for me.
Mississippi went to Chicago.
But the one I was there was so cold it must have been in 50 or 60.
61, 60 or 61, 60, 59 and 60.
It was so cold in Chicago, I didn't even open the front door.
My husband would come through the back door to keep the cold air from coming through the front door.
So I stayed there that year and I said,
What were you doing?
He was working there.
Working at a couple of places called We Boat.
We Boat in Chicago? Big department, still.
He was a salesperson, not in there.
But I just couldn't take that cold weather.
So I stayed in and I promised myself when the weather changed, I'm going home.
I told him I was going home but he said, no, I got to work.
I got to work.
So I kept fussing about him going home and going home and we finally came home.
And he came home and he started farming.
And that's how we got back here.
Maybe it was your family farm?
No, he had a farm here.
His family had a farm just like my family had a farm.
Same process through the farm and home administration.
So you were independent then?
White people in terms economically.
Well, we didn't share crop but we had to go to the the Farm Security Administration (FSA) for loans.
And they created the problem, you know.
But we made it pretty good.
I remember one year my father made one bale of cotton.
one bale of cotton.
Everybody laughed at him and saw him feel sorry for him as to how he was going to take care of family.
Well, one bale of cotton.
We had cows, holes and everything else, you know.
We only had to buy sugar and flour because there was a man with a grits meal in the community ground, a corner for meals and grits.
So we made it.
And with the auction and all of that, we had, we worked but we had to be some living, didn't have any money though.
Did you have much contact with Warts?
No.
We would see them passing by.
But now there were two merchants in the area.
There was a merchant in Belzoni, there was a merchant in Cardis.
My father would trust us to go there to get what we needed.
And the next day we needed meat or something like that of sugar.
He made provision for us to go there and get what we needed like that.
I heard Belzoni was pretty tough, too.
It was.
Belzoni now is, I don't think it's bad now.
You're back at the time.
At the time it was, people were really afraid to go to Belzoni.
They were lier than one, on when they were afraid.
Now they were lier than one of Belzoni.
And once you got in there, you picked up your items and hurried out of Belzoni.
There were a family of boys down below us, the Buckston boys.
They had to go to town every Saturday night, so to say them.
And it was always a problem with those boys.
Because the father had to go back there Sunday morning and get them out of jail.
But we didn't experience that.
We knew where to stay at home.
I mentioned this because among civil rights workers,
Belzoni was known as a really tough town.
And when they were having a debate about bringing in the freedom of summer volunteers,
they said, well, we're going to bring white style to sort of cause trouble.
And one woman person said, well, let's bring a thousand of them put them all in the same way.
Belzoni could not have hold of a thousand.
So, yeah, another.
And then after you came back from Chicago, why, what did you do?
After I came from Chicago, there was a principal by the name of SB Marshall.
Marshall High School.
He was a principal at the time.
And I came back and told him that I wanted a job.
And I was hired that same fall.
At that time, school was started in September.
We got back from Chicago in August.
And I told him that I wanted to work.
And he had me for the September session.
Did you have a divided session then?
No, it was all the same.
We were back on the nine months, got you.
Right.
And I guess it was, no, one nine month, eight months.
Eight months, eight months, eight months.
And where were you teaching then?
Marshall High School right up there on the hill.
Did you say your past?
Oh, I see you were here.
Right here, right up here.
I'm in Tchula, now.
Okay, you moved here with your family.
And...
I had one child at that time.
That's my oldest son, Reginald.
And your husband was farming?
He was farming.
And when he came back, at that time, the movement was just about to get started.
And several people were working around getting the movement started.
So he finally got a job teaching...
And the Civil Rights Movement called it, I believe, was SNCC at the time.
It's NC.
Yeah, it's SNCC.
Okay, so he went there and he worked with them.
And finally got a job with his Child Development Group of Mississippi.
You remember that?
Yeah, we were going to get there.
Okay.
So what I'm saying, he was farming at the same time working with the people to get the movement going.
So he was much more involved with the movement than I was.
As a teacher, why you were limited in some ways?
Very much so.
Very much so because there was a man by the name of John Ball, I believe it was John,
came out of Greenwood and by my husband being actively involved with the Civil Rights Movement,
I guess he thought I would be too.
And he did.
He came by the school and was telling me what was going on.
I didn't know in the bill that I'm standing up there in the hallway just talking to him about what I was going to do and everything.
And the principal came by.
And he didn't say anything, he just passed by.
But in a way, when John Ball left, he told me I was going to eventually lose my job if I didn't let that alone.
Okay, that's I'm glad to hear that.
That's evidence that this thing is going to be.
Yeah, he told me that if I didn't let them...
Now if I didn't let them freedom workers alone, I was going to lose my job.
And naturally, I didn't go bowling with it, but they would come by the house in the afternoon or at night, Saturday afternoon or Saturday night.
They didn't park in the driveway like people had been parking.
So my house was had a driveway around the back.
So they would come and park their cars behind the back of the house so it couldn't have one see them.
So you were very much aware of what was going on?
So during that time...
Yeah, I knew I heard that a number of teachers were sort of behind the scenes doing things.
They couldn't do public.
Right, because many times they wanted lemonade or tea cakes and I would cook and fix some refreshments, you know, while they passing through, they would stop and eat with me and move on or stop and eat.
And you know, we share ideas.
But like you said, behind the scene, I was very active, but all front I was afraid.
Not necessarily afraid, because I really didn't have sense enough to be afraid.
I didn't know what to expect, but I needed to work, so I just kept a low key there.
So what was... you came back to... you came to Chudolain what year then?
Sixty... 63, 62.
Okay, so that was one thing we're really getting underway with SNCC.
Right.
So with the Freedom Vote, that ball, and also the Freedom Summer of the next year when there are about 30 volunteers coming in.
It's about what you remember about Freedom Summer.
Freedom Summer, for me, was the time when a new man named Abe and somebody came...
Hey, Abe Osheroff, yeah.
Yeah, came to work with the Mileston community.
And at that time they were telling me to build a place to meet because they were meeting an old dilapidated church there in that same area.
So Abe came in and they built that... what we call the Mileston...
Oh, it was a Mileston Community Center.
And that's where we would start meeting.
Now I could go there because it was at home, okay.
But anyway, during that time, there was very...
Quite a few people were working and quite a few people were attending this...
You know, the...
I guess you call it the work session that they were having as to how to do when you get ready to vote and how you conduct yourselves and all of that.
They prepared people to go out and vote.
But now prepare people to register and later to go out and vote.
So you was at Henry Lorenzi, Sue Lorenzi, in the fall of 64.
Right. I remember them, yes.
They were all very well, very well.
Sue Lorenzi was young lady.
Henry was young fellow and Henry told me one thing I never forget.
He said, Ms. Burns, you're going...
No, you don't...
Why did you tip that on that?
Ms. Burns, you think people like you.
And I said, how is that?
He said, you understand fair.
People are not understand fair.
I never would forget that.
Hey, you tell me people are understand fair.
You know, I was understand fair.
People are not understand fair.
And he looked at me just as strange.
I heard Henry's story.
Oh, Henry was something else, not.
He would tell you just what he thought about you though.
But at the same time, he really worked hard to help the people in the community.
I appreciate that too.
So we have the Freedom Summer coming on and the formation of the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party.
That was your husband involved with all of this?
He was.
He was one of the ones who asked to did the teaching of the registration,
voted to get out and all of that, along with...
I don't know if anyone ever mentioned to you, Reverend Whitaker,
you remember Reverend Whitaker?
Yes.
They all worked together.
Reverend Russell.
And there was a little young lady about a name of Emma Nola Williams,
you remember her?
No.
Emma Nola Williams worked in that class also, Bernie Smangum, right?
Yes, she was a teacher.
Right, she was a teacher too.
But those are the ones who Bernie's was working in.
She came to Boston too, but that was the one who read was...
All of these people, I think, named were standing in the Mileston community except Rev. Arrell Whitaker.
He lived in Tchula, but he was a person who wanted to have a better life,
so he would come down and work with them.
And there was another young man named Marshall.
Marshall was out from the Roosevelt Bank Monologue community.
I believe it was F.D. Marshall.
You remember that name?
Okay.
Anyway, they all worked together.
And that's how the Child Development Group of Mississippi...
Head Start program got started, and they worked with that.
I particularly glad to have you as a teacher here teaching during this time,
because it was in 1965 that a federal court ordered Holmes County to be getting desegregating its all white schools.
Okay.
Talk about that from your perspective in the second year of high school and the parents of the kids.
At that, during the year 65, I was not teaching.
I was pregnant.
You know, during that time, if you were pregnant, you couldn't teach school.
But anyway, my son was going into the first grade, second grade.
I'm not sure.
And he was one of the ones who went to the Tchula Consolidated School,
the Tchula High School, which was a white school in town.
The Tchula who came out of first grade that year went to first grade at that school to integrate it.
Your son was one of those?
My son was one of those.
What was about his experience in your...
Well, now as a parent, we were trying to make life better for everyone.
And, um, it was about a little afraid now, because they went to school,
and I don't know what was a week of money, what have you, but the school burned down.
They burnt the school down when they found out that the black people were coming in.
And the next, after the children didn't get scared and run,
and the parents didn't pull them out, they burned another segment,
another part of the school down.
They was trying to run them out, but my son and that group, they stayed.
And...
Were you working at group of black kids that integrated?
I think was 16 in his first grade class.
I don't know.
Considerable number.
Right, right.
I don't know about the other class.
I just remember the class that my son was in.
I think it was 16 in his class.
And Christopher Epps, you heard of him?
Yeah.
Christopher Epps was my son's classmate.
And Christopher and I was a director of my freshman.
Did he have...
Did he come home when I cried about...
No, no, he never did complain about anything, but his teacher, his teacher was whipping me.
He didn't like getting a whipping at all.
So my son never...
Did you hear any white friends there?
They weren't there, they left.
All the white...
They all left when the blacks got there, they all the whites left.
I see, so it just...
It left it all black.
So that re-saggregation happened there really early this year.
That's right.
And you mean that way ever since?
It's been never way ever since.
So they finally got rid of the...
I think there's one building left and there was a shop building.
The shop building is there now.
But they burned everything else down.
Mm-hmm.
They was determined not to be there with those black children.
They went to Cruger-Tchula Academy and developed a Cruger-Tchula Academy Tchula Academy.
Okay, so...
I don't know what it was called before then, but later on it turned out to be the Cruger-Tchula Academy Tchula Academy.
So here, like we grew up, we were in Jackson at the time.
Okay.
There was integration of schools and for a while you had black and white kids going to school together
and then the whites would pull out.
But this happened just practically overnight?
It did, it did here.
Well, when they found out that the blacks...
The same black group of people from Austin who are not afraid to go register vote had children.
All of those children went together to integrate the Tchula Consolidated School.
And when they found out that that's what was going on, they just stopped burning the plays down.
No.
Okay.
And then they built the segregation of the Academy.
Right.
Shortly thereafter.
After that, right.
So then you came back to school to teach in 1966?
I came back in 1967.
I was out two years ago.
So talk about that experience.
That was a pleasant experience for me.
I had no problem of coming back to school.
I had no problem coming back to school.
Not the facility, not the setup that was there.
It wasn't smooth sailing, but it was better than I was first introduced to.
What kind of opportunities were there for your students?
And many of them got to go on to college or junior college?
Many went on to college.
And some did go to junior college.
But at that time, at home, right, it was over then.
They would go right on to college.
Mississippi Valley State, Jackson State and all core.
Still going into a predominantly black area.
That's all they were used to.
And by that time, really, they were the one who recruited those students who wanted to come.
It was recently that the white institution came to recruit the black children.
When was...
Did you recall when the first...
Your high school students went to Ole Miss or one of the white schools?
Oh, no.
That was very recently.
The university saved, of course, in 1962.
And there were a handful.
And now there are more black students there than there are two blue.
Because we had a student who finished about four years, maybe five years ago.
And he was...
I mean, he enrolled at Ole Miss and he was accepted.
I don't know what you heard of Antoine Patrick, the Patrick down on my cellar.
He finished at Ole Miss, returning.
So, that's still about it.
Oh, you know, let me get to you.
Straight about 80.
No, almost 80.
92.
93, something like that.
So, compared to that with now, are there more kids going to college now than back then or fewer?
Are they going to different places?
Back then, there were few.
And the problem then was because of finance.
They didn't have grants and loans and fellowships and scholarships like they have now.
And that made the number few because parents were not able to send them off to school.
But now, you have more students, I think, going to school.
But I really want to believe it.
I hope I'm wrong.
That they go in for the wrong reason.
Because I see them going to school and all of a sudden they get the grant money and go buy a car.
And they drop out of school.
Now, compared to what happened then after what's going on now,
the majority of the students went to school then for a good purpose.
They had a reason for going.
But now they're trying to be the system.
And that's Bay.
But I see a lot of that in my community.
I hear quite a bit of that too.
I hear some of the teachers get their degrees that way online.
I think it's Bay.
I think it's Robin, I was students of the very necessity of being trained by people who have been trained.
Now, believe it or not, those people who get those degrees online, that's compared to how I got in mind.
I just don't see them being as concerned as that was.
And I'm working right along there with them now.
Well, this is certainly up.
And you read recently where these are places where students have gotten college loans and the online universities have taken them and they drop out rates just over a while.
It is. It is.
Equipment and poach out.
Well, I want to turn to something out that is a very interesting thing.
And that is state that election to win.
Tell us why you ran for the school board and about that campaign.
Was that your first venture and electoral politics?
It was.
I ran because, like I said, keeping up with the movement now.
And I knew the situation when it comes to education because I'd been a parent, was a teacher.
And I said, well, let me do something to make it better.
If I was a board member, I could do something about the problem that I was facing.
So I ran and I was elected.
I stayed there until, um, seventy, seventy, seventy five or seventy six.
Did you campaign for the election?
I did. I did. I campaign hard.
Well, you got knock on doors for you.
Um, not really knock on doors per se.
Just out there in the churches and the communities letting people know that I was out there.
Interesting making a better life and education for the children and the teachers.
And everybody went for it.
Campaign and during that time is not like campaigning now.
If you had a cause or reason to go, they will support you because they wanted things to be better.
And that's the way it went for me.
Now, you were one against the white candidate.
Well, unfortunately, his name was not on the ballot.
Let me go back.
When I stood out to run, he was alive and well.
I guess by the first time the black person opposed him, he just couldn't take it.
He died the night before the election or two nights before the election.
I said, when I started out, he was alive and well.
But he just couldn't make it.
Martin Smith. I never forget it down there.
So by now, the schools are overwhelming.
They are totally black and yet they're still having white infositions of power.
They still had a white superintendent and white board members, white attorney, white everything.
When I won the election, I think I was the second black person on the board.
Others all white.
There was a leader on there already by the name of Dr. Arenia C. Mallory, the Saints Industrial School name for her.
Dr. Arenia C. Mallory.
She was on the board.
Dr. Arenia C. Mallory was okay.
She just, oh, how can I describe him?
She saw things the way the white folks saw things.
She told me one day right across the table from me.
You're sitting up here, you're trying to get everything, white folks, not everything,
not black folks, they're going to make you alive and stalkers of the community out a while.
I just couldn't believe that.
Because everything that teachers and the parents were asked for, I didn't have any better sense.
I went and told them to sit and turn to the board what we wanted.
And she thought there was true aggressive, I guess, because she didn't ask for anything.
She didn't bother about anything.
Everything was okay for her.
But she was on the board, but she had the academy going.
There was a college, anyone in the academy.
Why do I have heard a lot about her that she was very opinionated and that she was doing things
and that was the way to do it?
So you were on the board with her, how many were on the school board?
Five.
And there were three whites?
Three whites and two blacks.
Talk about what issues you deal with in the school board during the time you were with her.
We deal with the issues of staff and mostly.
Funding.
And we end up dealing with building.
Teacher shortage, not enough teachers.
Poor curriculum structure.
Just everything that we deal with now.
Now in the school, the white's bull are still white's teaching in the school.
Yes, so we got white steel teaching.
I mean, back then, some stayed, some went with the...
All of them left.
The children left and the teachers left.
But the academies began to phase out.
All the academies.
We got one, I think, in homes, countless, and likes it to them.
So the teachers didn't have anything to do.
You understand what I'm coming from now?
So where did the white school and the academies phase out?
They went to the other public school.
They didn't come back to the homes kind of now.
They went to Greenwood or...
They left the education system all together.
And their families moved or did they just pay to go to the other...
They paid to go.
But in Durant, they set up the separate school district in Durant.
And that accommodated the white because the white's in this era who couldn't afford to pay for the academies,
they went to the Durant school.
They stayed in operation.
But eventually all of the whites left there because it was in flux with black students.
So all the white teachers left but on the school board, you hired whites to teach in the schools here?
Yes.
These were younger people.
Younger people with different kind of experiences.
Did they work out, okay?
They did.
It worked out well.
So what was the racial makeup of when you...
You left the board in 1976.
1976, right?
What was the racial makeup of the faculty?
Generally, I know you don't...
Black and white?
Yeah.
We probably had...
At the most, probably two whites in each school.
At the most, it was not necessarily a white teacher, but a white was there.
And what did you have in your first black superintendent?
The black superintendent came along with the election of William Dean.
I'm not sure what he was.
I'm not good with dates like that.
William Dean.
Who had him?
Was it in the 80s or 90s or more recently?
Late 80s.
So you had a white superintendent up until then?
Right, up until then.
Before we let you go, there's something that I'm really interested in having you.
And ask back to your professional career that I want you to talk about.
Okay.
Now that way, as you were an actor participant in the research conducted on the Black family and Holmes County by University of Illinois professor of Dr. Demitri Shimkin and his associates.
And the result was a highly praised book, The Extended Family and Black Societies published in 1968.
Tell us about that project and your role in it.
That project grew out of the...
Like I said, the Mileston Cooperative.
There was a Mileston Cooperative that helped to initiate the Holmes County Health Research Program.
From the Holmes County Health Research Program, we went through house to house, door to door, studying students, studying people.
And we found that there were people with more hypertension problems than we had realized.
We didn't know what to expect.
And then we discovered that there were a child as young as six years old suffering from hypertension.
I never would forget that.
That was hard to believe.
Because I thought there was an old person disease.
Yeah.
And we had a child in there with hypertension.
That was a situation where we all were meet together and they were going to survey families, health condition.
And with the health condition, they also proved into the economic condition.
And all of that, they would go around to see if you have bathrooms and running water and all that kind of stuff.
It was a time where the Holmes County Health Research was trying to find out what did people have in Holmes County, help-wise.
And it worked out well with Dr. Demitri Shimkin and...
Well, I can't call other names.
What was your...
My role was secretary of the Holmes County.
Now my role was secretary for the Mileston Cooperative, which funded the Holmes County Health Research Program.
And I was just a go-between between the University of Illinois and the Holmes County people.
So I guess I was just all around finding out what was going on.
And I would communicate with Dr. Demitri Shimkin as to what we needed to do.
And I would feed it to the people in the Holmes County Health Research Program, other cooperation.
And they would care out those activities.
Okay.
What things did you recommend?
Recommended that we needed to look at economic development.
And you know, you needed more money within the county.
And eventually there was a program developed called Robert F. Kennedy Economic Development.
And rather than the clock, it was the chairperson of that.
The things that Dr. Demitri Shimkin would tell us that we needed, I would share with the community people.
And they would, you know, come up with a way of developing them.
And from that also now, we will talk about lunches in the school.
Holmes County Health Research Program looked at what was going on into the school, especially when the chair got to be up to 30 degrees.
And that's why we decided to have lunches for the children, the breakfast.
We started with the breakfast called the lunch program.
Do you have a health care that you have a component there?
In the school system?
Well, in the study, when you said you studied health care, were there any solutions proposed or programs initiated?
Of course you had the community health centers coming in.
Well, with Dr. Demitri Shimkin, and I can't think of this other doctor's name, but anyway, he came by and we developed a health facility, something like a clinic.
And from that clinic, you know, we were able to study and work with some of those people who had a problem.
Now, do you eradicate them now? We studied and work with them in order that they would have a better health.
You also studied black migration.
Yes, we did. What were you finding, sir?
The population shift within the county.
And one time there were plantations all around.
And the population shift because in the cities like Lexington and Pickens and Goodman and Durant, they built apartments.
They called them, I guess, the apartment.
And the people on the plantation came into the city and they left nothing out in the country.
So they migrated to the city.
By that sharecropping was...
Dwellen, Dwellen, Fas.
What about Didin Gideon with Northern migration and all you talked about members of your own family leaving?
Was that something that you studied?
I studied that, but we noticed that it was going on because, like I said, people in the community, they left and went to Chicago for a better job.
Whether it was not with the Wisconsin, Peoria and Oil.
Believe it or not, the majority of the people who left here settling some of those areas.
Chicago, Peoria, Wisconsin, and like that.
Did you studied all the impact of the civil rights movement on families?
I cannot recall.
Obviously, we could see that things were changing and things were getting better for them because of the civil rights movement.
Many people never thought that they were in the shape that they were in until they looked at by those civil rights workers.
It opened your eyes to a whole lot of things.
I guess we were poor and we didn't know we were poor until someone told us we were poor.
Talk to us a little bit about your career over the last 35 years.
We've taken it up to the end (of my time) on the school board.
After the school board, while on the school board, I worked at (Mississippi) Valley, English and Literature.
I stayed into 76.
Came back into the public schools of Holmes County.
I've been working in the public schools system at Holmes County ever since then.
Pretty good.
What are you still teaching now?
I'm teaching three hours a day part time.
I retired in 2006.
They told me then they was looking for someone to replace me in my foreign language department.
I teach French.
Here it is 2012, 2013.
Then I'm found a person here.
So when did you pick up French?
I did French when I was a student at (Mississippi) Valley.
Being on the school board, you just about know what's coming down the pipe.
We were trying to revamp our curriculum, make it better.
I had a chance to look at the curriculum from the state.
I always tried to compare what our district was doing as to what the state had done or what the state had to offer.
I saw that foreign language was coming into the state.
It was mandated that each child who goes into a state institution had to have a foreign language.
So I said, oh, no, I can't express more of my foreign language.
I went back to school and got me some French.
Where did you go?
I went to (Mississippi) Valley.
I was telling a cheer about it.
When you went to every school in the state, didn't it?
I went to (Mississippi) State, (no) Delta State.
So you got certified?
Right.
I was doing this for the principal.
I would go every summer.
Nothing to do doing this summer.
You know, teachers don't have anything to do.
I have a job in education in school.
And I'm still there with it.
And I love my job.
I really do.
It's something I enjoy doing.
And I don't consider the job.
No, I don't.
Because I feel like it.
But I feel like going every day.
God has been good to me.
So I get up and go to work every day.
And I have fun with my job.
Well, I just want to thank you very much for your service.
Just one thing here.
From that to the Freedom Summer.
It was my work and I worked long.
Reporter.
Work long?
No.
Okay.
Now, he may have been up to here, but there were so many of them.
And they were spaced out in the county.
All of them did not come to the Mileston community.
So he may have been here in home's county, but I didn't make that name.
Okay.
I think we're off to take now with the director of banks again.
You know you're welcome.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.